le capitaine thomas sankara chef de
l'état du burkina faso c'est l'ancien
volta a été tué ainsi qu'une dizaine de
ses compagnons d'armé immédiatement
enterrées le coup d'état a été mené par
le numéro deux du régime ami personnel
du président sankara le capitaine
comporte le putsch semble avoir réussi
et il y aurait eu de violents combats
dans la capitale ouagadougou
actuellement la situation semble calme
toute la matinée michel mompontet a
recueilli toutes les informations
possibles vous allez l'entendre en ce
moment même les communications
téléphoniques sont coupées un message
simplement est toujours diffusée à la
radio
dites moi si hier soir on pouvait
entendre sur les ondes de la radio
nationale du burkina faso mais c'est
seulement ce matin vers 11 heures que
l'on apprenait que le capitaine thomas
sankara avait été tué lors de ce coup
d'état
les combats ont cessé dans les rues
désertes de ouagadougou ce qui laisse à
penser qu'avec la mort de thomas sankara
blaise compaoré l'auteur de ce coup
d'état serait entièrement maîtres de la
situation
un membre de l'ambassade de france à
ouagadougou nous raconte les premières
heures de ce coup d'état
4h30 on a commencé à entendre des coups
de feu notamment du côté de la radio
nationale ces coups de feu ont duré
environ une demi heure après l'émission
à la radio les tirs ont tiré les tirs
avant automatique l'armée ou de ce
centre le couvre-feu a été décrété de
19h à 5h et bata tu es l et les
frontières terrestres et aériennes sont
fermés thomas sankara était âgé de 34
ans il a été renversé par le numéro deux
de son propre régime le capitaine blaise
compaoré
un officier de 36 ans cet officier lui
reprocher sur l'autocratie peut-être
mais surtout la rapidité des changements
qu'il imposait à l'un des pays les plus
pauvres de l'afrique noire
thomas sankara adeptes du verbe
révolutionnaire et du geste
spectaculaire symboliser pour bon nombre
d'observateurs le nouveau visage des
dirigeants de l'afrique noire
ses amitiés avec kadhafi il y avait
porté préjudice l'an dernier déjà il
confiait ses craintes et ses difficultés
devant les caméras d'antenne 2 si vous
voulez je me retrouve un peu comme un
cycliste qui comme une pente raide qui a
à gauche à droite des précipices il est
obligé de pédaler le continue de pédaler
sinon il tombe alors pour rester
moi-même et promet sentir moi mais je
suis obligé de continuer à sept
lancements
vous vous sentez isolé en afrique
mal compris en tout cas mal compris mal
aimé manu